big left-hander sean manaya takes the
mound for his 31st start of the season
for sean manaya we've mentioned how good
things were early on where we're at
today second half maybe been a little
bumpy but
got a couple starts left and one right
here against an astros team that you
would love to be able to take the second
game of take the series from jose altuve
will lead things off altuve
scored the only two runs for the astros
in last night's game
and he swings to the first pitch and
starts this one off with a line drive
down the left field line
marcano will dig it out of the corner
but altuve with an easy stand up double
to start this one carlos correa
correa on the ground
scooped up by elvis anders to throw in
time so sean manaya gives up a lead off
double nothing else so nice job of
getting out of the jam by manaya back in
oakland from valdez has taken the mound
second game of this three-game series
against the oakland a's he has been very
good on the road against the angels in
anaheim for his 11th win of the year
and that curveball looking good early
picking up a strikeout on the dangerous
starling martay for out number two so
kyle tucker to lead things off against
sean manaya
i think he went
well now they're saying
tucker says it hit me we're also saying
maybe a foul tip
and the third base umpire viscote said
no swing let's see if it hits tucker
he's going to tell you this glanced off
his forearm
let's take another look
maybe his knuckle they're saying foul
ball caught
out three two pitch and that's a swing
and a miss on a chain jump back-to-back
strikeouts for mania two away here in
the second inning
twinkling to miss chucky mountain mania
strikes out the side all three swinging
so we're going to the bottom of the
second no score
what a play by jose altuve up the middle
astros infielders have to be on their
toes with a guy that has a ground ball
percentage like fraumber valdez
got a great jump on that maybe a little
help from the mound slowing it down but
a great play finish off by the spin move
and long hop and gets canon by quite a
bit so top of the third jose siri
leading things off another young
outfielder for the astros
got him swinging anyways that's four
straight strikeouts for sean
chris davis leading things off
so davis on a very close pitch in fact
trevor valdez is walking
around the grass he can't believe that
that was called the ball
[Music]
got him murphy strikes out it's the
second strikeout for frauber one away
here in the third even though that at
bat started 2-0 against murphy it was
pretty uncomfortable and frauber valdez
took control of it with a couple of
fastballs and then a breaking ball where
the lower half of murphy completely
broke down no one away for alex andrews
in the hole by alba sanders and that's
going to be a base hit
thomas finds the hole
on the season he's usually 92-93 there's
94. so he started up with 91 went up to
92 and then got him with 94.
three strikeouts now for proper three
pitch strike out of harrison
two out base runner for kyle tucker
one two pitch a high fastball and mania
got it past it
five strikeouts for sean manaya bottom
of the fourth coming up no score
this ball hit hard oh what a play by
correa carlos correa takes one away from
matt olsen on a diving play on a rocket
up the middle
as this ball is rocking it up the middle
at
110.5 miles an hour
and carlos no time but just to react and
dive to his
right be here
grabs a little snow cone
that's the second out
when you're an athlete
you make the adjustment
he had it the whole time
a little ground ball back at you
ease it on over to matt olsen siri with
a pretty good lead he's not going
anywhere and that's a swing and a miss
joe maldonado strikes out to end the
innings six strikeouts for sean manaya
bottom of the fifth coming up now here's
a 3-0 to olson that's inside that's a
four-pitch walk and that'll bring up
pinder
black drive right field that's a base
hit here in the seventh inning carlos
correa kyle tucker marwyn gonzalez 2-2
swing and a miss tied him up good slider
under his hands and correa is strikeout
at victim number seven
of shaw manaya kyle tucker has struck
out a couple of times
that ball hit high in the air pretty
deep right field all the way back pender
to the wall that ball's gone
kyle tucker with his fourth career home
run against mania
and a game dominated by pitching has a
run on the board thanks to tucker's 28th
home run all hail
king tuck got up
wanted that pitch elevated up and away
not up and in and kyle tucker amazingly
has hit his fourth home run off of sean
manaya
to put the astros ahead and there's your
barrel ball tk
astros is a home run and now marwin
shoots one off mania's foot
in the left field and marwin might have
a chance to go for two but he will hold
up and try and hustle back to first and
does
the astros have two hits on back-to-back
pitches after having one hit through six
and a third the pitch sean meyers
right-hand batter swing and a miss and
him on the changeup
that is out number two strikeout number
eight if kd can't get himself a little
fast ball outer third
pitch is driven to right tucker back
tucker turns around it's off the top of
the wall tucker grabs it fires it back
in and it's a long single for chris
davis jay hayes oh for three is grounded
out struck you out and grounded out
again
little flair correa back can't get it
this game is going to be tied sky ball
scores
minding himself fighting that ball off
like he did there what was interesting
was watching jay hey
talking with bushy darren bush the
hitting coach as draymond was coming in
they're looking at the ipads and you can
see jay hey kind of talking about
defending the inner half of the plate
knowing what you're gonna get from
kindle braveman
match-up we've all been waiting for
elvis versus presley
pitches bounced in the left field of
base hit
craigman dove could not come up with it
and the winning run is aboard with
nobody out that'll bring up marte who's
hole for four
this one has driven right center field
nobody's gonna get it
here comes alessandra's they're waving
them home and the throw
and is scores and the azab won it in the
bottom of the ninth in walk-off fashion
thanks to starling martay's double
elvis andrus
struggled to get to home plate he kind
of fell on home plate and he may be
injured
just before he got to home plate he kind
of slowed down and
he is down right
near home plate and being checked by the
eighth training staff
so the a's have won the game let's keep
our fingers crossed that elvis anders is
okay as the whole team now heads over
toward him at home plate